so you've talked about your son coming
out so what lessons have your kids
taught you honestly Kelly they teach me
more lessons I think than I teach them
they teach me a lot about language I was
really had a hard time wrapping my brain
around the gender pronouns because to me
they they is plural and so I'm I'm you
know I'm a dinosaur
in a way of that so they teach me and I
think you know they're not always
patient so that can shock at times but I
main thing is for me that I have to try
they teach me the issues they're so much
more aware of because they're living
them my son came out in the seventh
grade you know he was I just thought he
was the bravest thing ever and you
really see other people's reactions to
it you end up knowing who people are or
how they think and then it'll feed me
the facts and tell me what's up with
with the protest I always like to think
I know things but they know more so my
job a lot right now is to listen to
listen and learn listen and learn yeah I
think that's a lot of our job is
educating ourselves and it is funny
again as a mom I like it's when I even
have weave kids ranging from 4 to 19 in
our household but it's like you find out
I mean yes you're helping mold this life
but you also are you're changing like it
changes you in the best way and it
really does make you like
self-examination become so prominent and
like what you say and that you get
called out like your kids are like wait
what and then you hear them say and
you're like oh maybe I shouldn't do that
like it's like it really does change you
and it's in it when I think it changes
you when you're a present great parent I
think so you must be you know we we are
you I'm not gonna say we don't we argued
I want to understand well so do we
yeah and it's part of it I think that
first of all you know we're in drama
right so you feel like there's no real
world without drama without conflict and
there's no college without conflict so I
get it but you know but there's a
everything is in such flux right now and
the world is changing hope
live for the better but it's bringing
out just so much hatred and so much
anger and you don't want to give up on
systems that you knew felt safe with but
then now you see them in a new light you
go oh I guess we need a new system and
then it's the forming of that system
that I'm probably more old world old
world I wanna you know be careful as we
form it and they're like excuse my
crashing for the way yeah Rick never
mind you know caution to the wind
let's have change now subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going